[Music]
foreign
[Music]
DC Comics has enjoyed a television
presence since the early 1950s with
Adventures of Superman which made
genuine cultural touchstones out of the
1966 Batman and the late 1970s Wonder
Woman it's over doctor
[Applause]
[Music]
it has never had so many of its titles
translated on television at the same
time before and nowadays DC shows are
all the rage new HBO Max series
Peacemaker a spin-off of James Gunn's
The Suicide Squad is the latest to join
the list along with Doom Patrol and
Young Justice welcome to the Hall of
Justice headquarters of the Justice
League oh man
I know we'd be the last ones here but
not all DC Universe titles are exclusive
to the HBO streaming service the CW for
example is home to many DC focused
properties for this list in particular
we're looking at the highest ranked
shows on the Tomato Meter so you may be
surprised to see the shows that we have
here on today's list so let's count down
the best DC Comics TV shows ranked by
Tomato Meter
foreign
[Music]
DC's Star Girl
high school student Courtney Whitmore
inspires an unlikely group of young
Heroes to stop the villains of the past
starring Breck the singer Luke Wilson
Angelica Washington Amy Smart and
created by Jeff Johns critics say a
stellar series perfect for anyone
looking for a little hope star girl is
delightful fun the whole family can
enjoy
what's up
hey there bud
what'd we miss our daughter broke us out
Berman called
I did
I am forever
I am not finished
yes you are he's weakened those who
command the light I'd act quickly
I wish this guy was toast
number nine Harley Quinn
the newly single Harley Quinn sets off
to make it on her own as the criminal
Queen pin in Gotham City starring Kaley
Cuoco Lake Bell Alan Tudyk Jim Rash and
developed by Justin Halpern Patrick
Schumacher and Dean Laurie critics say a
strong voice cast and an even stronger
grasp of what makes its titular
anti-heroine so beloved make Harley
Quinn a violently delightful and
surprisingly insightful addition to the
DC Animated Universe
oh Mr J oh sorry my bad you looked a
little like him I don't know why you
bother coming here he's never showing up
yeah but for the record he does have a
point just give me 15 more minutes
Joker's probably still fighting Batman I
don't know hon it's you know most
superhero fights they're not like
a calendar man how long has she been in
here oh hey Ivy 183 days oh sure
oh sure incarceration data Warren clown
over here but not your
Aaron I know it's Jewish it's okay Daddy
I brought you this Cactus to keep you
cold
[Music]
don't remember your birthday number
eight Peacemaker
a man fights for peace at any cost no
matter how many people he has to kill to
get it starring John Cena Daniel Brooks
Freddie stroma chicati awuji and created
by James Gunn critics say John Cena is
still in solid form and Peacemaker
leading a bloody good time that gives
writer director James Gone full
permission to let his freak flag fly
are you kidding me oh
did this [ __ ] really show up in full
cosplay mode this is the guy Waller's
giving us I told you she's [ __ ] up
she's not [ __ ] us is that an eagle in
his back seat
us
hey scooch
why are you in your costume
costume this is a uniform and it's brand
new so I gotta stretch it out make it
more comfortable before we're going to
Mission maybe I'm stupid but why would
you even want to wear that on a mission
a bright red shirt and white pants
aren't exactly conducive to lurking in
the shadows people see this uniform
strikes fear in their hearts what people
the other people at the Village People
try out why is there a bald eagle in
your car it's easy
you guys ordered without me
eagerly is your pet eagle yeah is your
dog named doggy all right do you have a
daughter named daughtery
jealous of a guy's Petty don't watch
number seven Young Justice
these teenage heroes are members of a
covert operation team Young Justice
starring Jesse McCartney Jason spysak
Kari Payton Danica McKellar and
developed by Brandon bayetti and Greg
Weissman critics say with its compelling
storylines well-drawn characters and
surprisingly poignant moments Young
Justice proves that these heroic
adolescents belong in the league of
outstanding Superhero Cartoons normally
NASA would study and mimic your
abilities during battle but what's the
point you're all such poor copies of The
Originals
so everyone keeps saying it makes me
angry
angry wanna see me gentle that anger
great he's gone ballistic again
anyone want to play keep away mixes
Superman
Martian Manhunter
[Music]
help me disassemble him now dude the guy
has no head don't take any chances
Superboy are you all right
we're fine number six Justice League
Batman Superman Wonder Woman The Flash
and other superheroes joined forces to
battle crime and otherworldly threats
keeping a watchful eye on Earth from
their orbiting space station starring
Kevin Conroy George Newburn Susan
Eisenberg and developed by Bruce tin
critics say Justice League offers a
surprisingly rewarding expansion of the
DC Universe in animated form
do it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
uh oh
number five Batman the Brave and the
Bold
the Caped Crusader teams up with several
other DC Comics heroes for new
adventures based on the comic book
series The Brave and the Bold starring
Dietrich Bader Corey Burton D Bradley
Baker Johnny Reese and developed by
James Tucker and Michael jelinek critics
say Batman the Brave and the Bold is a
thoughtful brighter iteration of the
Batman Universe children and adults can
enjoy
wait are you too flirting oh always
trying to declaw me Batman which is why
I must clip your wings
permanently not if I collar you first
you are you're flirting flirters
I told you we should have taken his belt
away
you two take the overground elf I'll
take the Batman
[Music]
[Music]
you chose the wrong career Batman
we could be partners in crime the
perfect power couple I'm a servant of
Justice
[Music]
this is always looking for new recruits
[Music]
can you believe those two yeah
shut your cat box pal number four
Watchmen Watchman takes place in Tulsa
Oklahoma 34 years after the original
story after a white supremacist attack
on the local police department which
leaves only two surviving cops on the
beat laws are passed that allow the cops
to hide their identities behind masks
one of these cops Angela abar adopts the
identity of sister Knight and fights
racists while dealing with a
decades-long legacy of the Vigilantes
starring Regina King Jeremy Irons Don
Johnson and created by Damon Lindelof
critics say bold and bristling Watchman
isn't always easy viewing but by adding
new layers of cultural context and a
host of complex characters it expertly
builds on its source material to create
an impressive identity of its own
foreign
foreign
you sure
he's not going to talk someone's
motivation but
he was off the charts on the biased
questions I was dilated on all the Royal
shocks yeah
I'm sure
like I said
bleach
number three Doom Patrol
Doom Patrol is a team of traumatized and
downtrodden superheroes each of whom has
suffered a horrible accident that gave
them superhuman abilities but also left
them scarred and disfigured the members
of the team have found their purpose
through the chief and have come together
to investigate some of the world's
weirdest phenomena after the chief
mysteriously disappears though The
Reluctant Heroes find themselves called
to action by cyborg who comes to them
with a mission that they cannot reviews
Doom Patrol part support group part
superhero team is a band of
super-powered freaks fighting for a
world that wants nothing to do with them
starring Brendan Fraser Matt Bomer April
Bowlby Diane Guerrero and created by
Jeremy Carver critics say DC Universe
finds breakout material in this
iteration of Doom Patrol thanks to a
fully committed cast and the writing's
faith in weirdness
man you must be one of now strays you
know the chief I do why didn't you say
you know the chief because watching you
try to be effective is real distracting
where is he
he's gone ground opened up swallowed him
and the whole town our housemate Jane
tried to save him now she's gone too
sorry
I just need a second just oh no go ahead
get this straight
how does a band of circus freaks manage
to screw up so badly that they lose
their leader and the whole entire town
at the same damn time Hey Monday morning
QB I'll feel good about it either did
you see who made the hole I was busy not
getting swallowed by it where's the hole
now it swallowed itself did you see
anything useful
he's the donkey got to do with it that's
what I'm trying to figure out
foreign
[Music]
number two Wonder Woman
Diana Prince a true Amazonian with
special powers fights off evil bad guys
in classical wham bam comic book style
Wonder Woman catches people in her magic
lasso of Truth and uses her Golden Belt
and bracelets to deflect things such as
bullets starring Linda Carter Lyle
Wagner Beatrice Colin Richard Eastham
and developed by Stanley Ralph Ross
critics say Wonder Woman is definitely
campy at times but series lead Linda
Carter adds extraordinary Grace and
gravitas to the proceedings whether
their Tales of World War II Intrigue or
over the top 70s crime stories
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Victory is always born under sacrifice
[Music]
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
Black Lightning
as a younger man Jefferson Pierce Don
the suit of a vigilante and protected
the streets of his City but he believed
he'd left those days in the past he
learns that life doesn't always work out
as planned when his daughter a star
student who is determined to achieve
Justice at any cost gets recruited by a
street gang in order to protect his
family Jefferson sees no choice but to
once again become Black Lightning
starring Cress Williams China Anne
McClain nefessa Williams Christine Adams
and developed by Saleem Akil critics say
Black Lightning doesn't reinvent
superhero TV but it does give the genre
a necessary jolt with real world plots
scary new villains and a star making
performance from Chris Williams
oh honey it's a misunderstanding honey I
I just need to go with these men and and
straighten it out everything will be
fine
Jennifer
I need you to do something very
important for me
Jennifer
I need you to be calm really calm
call your mother tell her what happened
be strong for your mother can you do
that for me
[Music]
Swamp Thing
Abby Arcane returns home to Murray's
Louisiana to investigate a deadly
swamp-borne virus where she develops a
bond with disgraced scientist Alec
Holland after Holland tragically dies
Abby discovers the mysteries of the
swamp and that Holland may not be dead
after all when a mysterious creature
claims to be him starring Crystal Reed
Andy Bean Derek Mears Virginia Madsen
and developed by Gary doberman and Mark
verhiden critics say by leaning into the
horror of it all swamping swings deep
into the trenches of this strange world
and returns with a scary good TV show
what is the purpose of showing me out of
this death they're warning you
there's danger here
you know
Danger from the past returning
foreign
[Music]
foreign
when overachieving medical resident Liv
Moore attends a party that turns into a
zombie Feeding Frenzy she ends up
joining the ranks of the Living Dead
determined to pass as a human despite
her pale appearance and newly listless
demeanor Lyft forms a plan to resist her
drive to consume fresh human brains by
taking a job at a coroner's office where
she can secretly snack on the brains of
corpses delivered there soon discovering
that she absorbs the memories of those
that she feeds on she finds new Purpose
By posing as a psychic and working with
a detective to help solve murders
starring Rose McIver Malcolm Goodwin
Raul Coley Robert Buckley and developed
by Rob Thomas and Diane rugiero Wright
critics say an amusing variation on the
zombie Trend iZombie is refreshingly
different if perhaps too youth-oriented
to resonate with adult audiences
ish
yeah who's laughing now
what are we 100 yards to the pen
should he use less Club no more than an
eight iron ladies and gentlemen this
golf ball gun means we're now
investigating a murder
yeah no duh
well you don't own the word
you hungry not really
you're thirsty though
[Music]
oh
foreign
Batman Beyond
a new Dark Knight protects the Gotham of
the future starring Will fridell Kevin
Conroy Chris summer Lauren Tom and
created by Bruce Tim Paul Denney and
Alan Burnett critics say a remarkable
step forward in the Batman Mythos Batman
Beyond's new black-winged red-blooded
Batman on display Saturday mornings will
have you pouring a steaming mug of
coffee and shouldering aside any nearby
children to catch all the fresh fun and
action
hello
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that's it
you're showing me everything
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content that you love
until next time I'm your host Naz Perez
and we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the Rotten Tomatoes countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]